let us turn now to rue preta Ruprecht
the pole ends one of these CD users at
top foreign policy makers welcome again
sir to DW let's look at this from the
German perspective the country's foreign
minister front Valtor Steinmeier says
this offensive is a turning point in the
fight against the jihadists is that an
opinion that you share yes I hope that
muscle will be freed by the coalition
against ash and i would emphasize the
difference between fighting i dash as it
is now done in muscle and what we see at
the very same moment in aleppo if you
turn to aleppo for instance you would
not be able to discuss with people from
the Red Cross about some kind of
humanitarian aid because what Russia and
the Syrian regime is doing pretending to
fight against Isis is totally different
here in muscle we are fighting against
Isis ok and we will talk more about a
telephone situation in Syria shortly I
wonder though if we in the West are
prepared for the prospect of is losing
control of its last and biggest strong
hole there in Iraq because if is lose
muscle will that not mean lots of
returning jihadists coming back into
Europe it could mean that but on the
other hand having this kind of control
about on land and territory like dash
tried to establish means to have safe
heavens for planning terrorism so you
could put it either way we have to fight
them as long as they don't stop to
international terrorism and it's sort of
taken a step back from them arriving
here one wonders what the coalition has
to do to stop dash fighters just
disguising themselves as civilians
fleeing from Mosul it might be difficult
but this is nevertheless should be the
task that fighters should be kept as
prisoners and then we have in all as in
many other cases the problem I
to bring them to the International
Criminal Court and/or to have
reactivation programs as we have seen it
in other cases as well what more should
Germany be doing in this fight we are
helping with a server with our tornadoes
and we are we have decided to add our
aid with regard to FX air reconnaissance
and I think this is what Germany can do
and we have also equipped Peshmerga
fighters with weapons so we are doing a
lot to support this coalition in the
fight against daesh but on the other
hand we are doing a lot of help to
overcome the terrible outcome of the
Syrian civil war and of the devastations
diache is doing in this country so just
that does that mean you you feel the
Germany has done enough there is no more
that generally could or should be doing
I i don't think the Germany will do more
in the military sense but we are doing a
lot with regard to helping the Syrian
population within the country and taking
refugees from Syria more than many other
countries and I think this is what we
are doing the United States and Britain
are talking about new economic sanctions
against Russia Chancellor Merkel is set
to back this move where are you on this
I'm on marcasite and I think you should
do what we can to stop what Russia is
doing together with Iran and the Syrian
regime in Syria if you look for instance
to Aleppo why we are talking children
and women are dying by Russian aircraft
or by barrel bombs thrown down from the
Assad regime and this has to be stopped
and if you cannot intervene militarily
because we have not the means not they
will take it how you like it we have to
use other means to stop the Russian
procedure it's interesting that you call
it a question whether or not the West is
able to do more because he clearly Z
article will now we have seen that the
United States for instance I'm not
willing to engage in them in a deeper
way as for instance they did in
Afghanistan or in Iraq there are united
states are telling us it's not our
national interest to stop the war in
Syria so can-can Germany can the EU only
proceed if the United States gets deeper
into this if we see on the one on one
side Russia of his nuclear weapons I
think it is impossible for Germany to go
in it to a direct confrontation with
Russia I would also not suggest the
United States should do it but to have
more pressure on Russia and on the
Iranian regime and on the Assad regime
to stop this war I think this is doable
and it is necessary and having more
sanctions would be one way to do it but
yeah well you mentioned that the the
fact that Russia has nuclear weapons you
do you anticipate you juicy and likely
heard a possibility of the conflict in
Syria going nuclear no I don't think so
but if you listen to Putin he is always
talking about this option he is now
sending a short-range missiles to
Kaliningrad to threaten the Baltic
States and these short-range missiles
can be equipped with nuclear warheads so
we see Russian moves Russian language
and we have to deal with it and not to
say we should also threaten with things
like that but we have to take it
seriously so the others talk of
increased financial sanctions what else
it depends you know we have sanctions
have the disadvantage that they usually
have an impact only let's say after
month maybe after years but nevertheless
sanctions have also political meaning
and this is immediate if russia for
instance would see that the European
Union is united even in its stint in
Syria vasavi the regime Iran and Russia
it would impress Russia but if
I see as it is unfortunately now the
case that even in Germany we have a
discussion we have two or even more
states within the European Union who
would not join in to further sanctions
then of course Russia is better off just
a final note then so we've talked about
what's going on in Syria and we've also
talked about what's going on in Iraq are
there any lessons that one conflict can
draw from the other yeah of course we
have learned from Iraq that it is easier
to to get Saddam Hussein overthrow and
then to establish a valid and strong
democracy in this country and this of
course will also be true finally in
Syria so we have to think about what
comes next yes thank you so much for
joining us Ruprecht pullins thank you
thank you